hey leute ich muss euch einfach mal mein
outfit jetzt gleich zeigen das ist doch
so krank das ist so ein richtiges
yachtbesitzer outfit man sitzt so am
strand mit so einer frau die 30 jahre
jünger ist als nicht so sehr ich gerade
aus was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zum 1 neu video ja ich habe mir
natürlich geht es gut
wie man heute folgendes und zwar geht es
um ich habe das oft gelesen so ich habe
das nie wirklich gemacht weil ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich bin jetzt auch
keinen fashion youtuber oder sollte ich
kann mich da ganz einfach nicht aus ich
habe keinen plan wann der letzte
valencia oder meinetwegen die letzten
valencia schuhe für 800 euro
herausgekommen sind habe ich mir auch
noch nie gekauft so dass plötzlich
hatten wir selbst geschrieben dass sich
doch bitte mal so fakes die aktuellste
fake sonst domain in valencia barcelona
bei uns bestellen soll
und habe ich gemacht haben wir jetzt
häufig nicht zu jedem kleidungsstück
auch das original aber ich denke ich
kann trotzdem gut sagen was das für eine
qualität ist und ob das richtig ist was
daran zeigt ist und soweit ich weiß
nicht mehr genau wie ich bestellt habe
es ist glaube ich auch schon ein
bisschen länger am netz gefangen war
einmal mit dem ersten kleidungsstücke
und das ist folgendes leute wir haben
hier eine louis wie cap louis vitton
also diese sollte man cool alter der 22
euro kostet plus 11 euro versand für
einen frieden will mal kurz checken wie
teuer das original das ist das ding ist
irgendwie ich finde die gar nicht
wahrscheinlich gibt es das ist es gibt
gar nichts es gibt nur
wie extreme kräfte davon gibt es ja auch
die symbole der wurde damals so für
10.000 euro verkauft dann habe ich
nämlich auch mal bestellt hier das weiß
ich noch aber diese cap gibt es gar
nicht im original leute ich fühle mich
schon ein bisschen schlecht es jetzt zu
sagen aber von der qualität her ist es
echt gut also kann man für 33 euro auch
erwarten ist jetzt zwar nicht so mein
geschmack aber irgendwie hat die auf was
schreibt gerne eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare
ich setzte sich gleich auf jeden fall
noch mal auch nur ich wollte jetzt mal
nicht meine schönen haare zustand nicht
aber die anderen sachen auspacken
ok
wow da kriege ich schon gar nicht wenn
ich das nur berühre ich merke jetzt
schon absolute rotz qualität wir haben
hier ein mentor wayne paris da kann ich
mich daran erinnern hat 13 euro +7
versand 20 euro für so ein fake pulli
mit bon herstellung höchstens vier euro
alter die qualität ist absolut ranzig
kostet im original sogar 450 euro das
soll sein ist ziemlich klein aber kommt
auch aus china
naja schmeißt war den uns immer über das
ist halt wirklich so krassen leute wenn
ihr euch irgendwie goodies aus china so
gestellt nimmt immer zwei größen größer
als ihr eigentlich befreit
das ist technisch l das fühlt sich an
die erste prämie also so sieht er aus
qualität absolut ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich finde ihn auch im original
absolut weg so das ist gar nicht voll
langweilig oder das soll jetzt natürlich
die man an reichten von euch wenn ihr so
ein pulli habt aber ich würde dafür sich
150 euro ausgeben das soll jetzt aber
nicht heißen dass ich stattdessen
anfängst anziehe oder sowas förderer
also ich habe das auch schon öfter jetzt
bei mir in den kommentaren gelesen dass
es da so heisst alex voll scheiße dass
du so fake fur das dann so jetzt bei
klamotten oder so ich würde es absolut
nicht fördern ich bestelle das halt nur
um mich vielleicht auch ein bisschen nur
bei lustig zu machen wie gesagt dieser
pulli ist absolut scheiße kann ich euch
auf keinen fall erzählt jetzt wird es
interessant da habe ich mich sehr
gefreut wir haben hier eines down and t
shirts 2020 sommertrend t shirt kann man
glaube ich ganz gut sehen
es ist sogar zwölf euro plus 7 euro
versand wir haben jetzt sogar sohnes
sohn einen tüte hier ist das logo drauf
und dann kann man das hier so aufziehen
also schon ziemlich professionell
gemacht und
das habe ich auch in elbe stellt auch
wieder mehr geht schon viel zu klein
wir haben ja auf der seite diesen stone
einem patch ok und hier steht auch im
etikett stone island sogar am schild
steht noch mal stone island also die
haben sich wirklich mühe gegeben ist so
ein ganz normales oranges t shirt ein so
stumpf korrigiert mich wenn ich falsch
liege
aber es gibt gar keine orangen ist allen
t shirt was diesen patch hier am ärmel
hat sondern da ist eigentlich nur hier
immer links das logo drauf dass hier so
dumm
das ist wirklich so traurig auf jeden
fall liegen die 720 euro hierfür habe
ich jetzt 20 uhr ziehen was mal kurz an
ja so sieht das aus ist halt und t shirt
also qualität von dem t shirt geht klar
ist auf jeden fall deutlich besser als
von diesem pulli den wir gerade an
hatten und das traurige ist ja wirklich
immer all diese sachen haben halt
bewertungen leute das wirklich ernsthaft
stellen da bewertungen schreiben und das
zum teil auch noch mit fünf sternen
bewerten very cool dass sie es jetzt das
nächste zeit 1 versace
also wer sagt es sowieso meiner meinung
nach die hässlichste marke die ich je
gesehen hab ich war mal in paris im
versace store
da war so eine persische küche die ganze
küche war voll mit so versagte
verkleidung und da war ein zug der hat
für 8000 euro eingekauft
ich glaube das war auch das günstigste
das fühlt sich an wie sowieso ein sport
so ein atmungsaktives sport shirt mal
immerhin ist das jetzt mal ein bisschen
größer beziehen was mal an ok nähe ist
es doch nicht also so sieht das aus auch
absolut da hat es gut ich weiß nicht was
ich sagen will bauermann l
es geht weiter mit folgenden produkt und
zwar ihr kennt doch diese gucci sneaker
das sind doch einfach so die standard
jessica wenn man gut skischuhe sieht
dann sind sie doch meistens die oder die
hat doch jeder shisha bar besitzer jeder
zweite fußballspieler hat diese schuhe
und da dachte ich mir nicht mit mir die
brauchst du auf und hat mir die einfach
mal gezogen für 24 euro plus 12 euro
versand meine sind vergoldet
ok
junge das sind die hässlichsten schuldig
in meinem leben gesehen habe was ist das
denn
leute ich zitiere mal kurz an
aber stabil alter so sehe ich mich schon
schön so mit meinen wenn ich 60 bin
irgendwie im urlaub in seiner schönen
strand bar
hey leute ich muss euch einfach mal mein
auto jetzt gleich zeigen das ist doch so
krank das ist so ein richtiges
yachtbesitzer outfit man sitzt so am
strand mit so einer frau die 30 jahre
jünger ist als ich so sehe ich gerade
aus halle oder nehmen so dieses network
marketing wenn man so wenn ihr so
werbefilme angezeigt bekommt jetzt
schnell geld verdienen und dann so mit
handy in der hand worte oder auch
einfach köln nach flug gib deine nummer
[Musik]
ja so nicht anders
leute hier noch ein kurze einspieler ich
muss das kurz noch mal aufnehmen weil
ich eben meine schuhe nicht zeigen
konnte die wollte ich euch natürlich
nicht vorenthalten gibt euch mein auto
für das ist einfach zu krank man wir
haben hier also wenn ich jetzt wer fragt
wie viel ist ein outfit wert der wird
dumm gucken wie ich komme einfach nicht
auf diese schuhe klar es fehlt jetzt nur
noch eine dicke uhren oder läuft das so
leicht bevor es vergessen ich habe euch
ja gar nicht mehr die keb gezeigt dritte
geht manchmal sogar hier ist dieses
louis wie logo drauf und so sieht man
dann aus wie man geld hat ne leute wie
findet ihr die cap ich weiß nicht
irgendwie sich aus wie mario ich muss
sagen also das meiste bestellt ich
musste niemand sowas auch wenn es an
sich ganz lustig ist aber ist
unglaublich schaut euch natürlich aus
zuschauen ich hoffe es hat euch bei
media markt und niederwürzbach york das
was du mir auch ein
[Musik]